at least blood pressure went down he
started sweating profusely
i think it went up
you're a trap jack you ready for two
more might as well just make it wow even
who gives a [ __ ] 10 at this point yeah
this show is brought to you by primal
blueprint primal blueprint
is a great great company that wants to
help you burn fat for fuel and revamp
weight loss
and they want they basically want to
make you a healthier better person so
what we what we're offering you is we're
gonna ask you to go to
primalblueprint.com joeyds they have a
lot of info they have a lot of great
products they have the 21 day total body
transformation program which please go
on on the first december you don't know
it yet oh nice it's gonna be a human
guinea pig first
no more [ __ ] tortillas it's over
[ __ ] you heard it here first i'm
going on the 21 day total transformation
program so just go to
primalblueprint.com joeyds for more info
really they have a lot of great products
go just check it out
primalblueprint.com
vanilla coconut
meal replacement okay and get back to me
[ __ ] and when you do that you're
gonna get 10 off of your entire order oh
[ __ ] it's not bad no it's not bad it's
not bad that's not bad anyone else isn't
bad but days because they're back
they're back jerry rocha but they are
back
and we're happy we're happy to
reintroduce you again every it's not
like we've been we've said it a couple
times but it's just so amazing
we want to introduce you to
hellotushy.com
hellotushy makes portable devices that
spray your butt clean with water jerry
roach that's the best no more jumping
into the shower imagine reading a comic
book while cold water is sprinkling your
hands it's the greatest day of my life
that's it are you kidding me who needs a
wife right what's going on you still got
the girlfriend oh yeah absolutely
nobody's gonna hit my cars
she's in florida right now she is yeah
but nah that's
finish it up
so go to hellotushy.com right now to get
the portable devices that spray your
butt clean with water go to
hellotushy.com church and you're going
to get 10 off of your order that's
hellotushy.com
church and the show is brought brought
to you by blue apron
for less than ten dollars a meal blue
apron delivers seasonal recipes along
with pre-proportioned ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meals check
out this week's menu and get your first
three meals for free with free shipping
by going to blueapron.com
joey that's blueapron.com joey to get
your first three meals for free with
free shipping include not bad
kick that [ __ ] mule lee
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
wednesday october 26th
so church of what's happening now uncle
joey with his little goomba the flying
[ __ ] jew
jerry rocha hey
bad [ __ ] comedian my little
brother for 20 years now the best oh
[ __ ]
this is the [ __ ] jam there we go
[ __ ] little madonna for you 83
kicking it
my body i don't mind go to lee shake it
[ __ ]
oh yeah
oh yeah look at him seductive as a
[ __ ]
you say you wanna stay the night oh [ __ ]
it's physical attract physical
attraction
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
welcome to another edition of the church
beautiful wednesday night here in
southern california thank you for
dropping in and seeing what's
crackalackin like i said earlier my
little brother what's on the podcast you
do the ramble the ramble uh jerry roach
i've known him for years he's on the
podcast tonight just to clarify the joke
over the holidays i've known jerry since
he was in [ __ ] diapers right oh yeah
i met him in [ __ ] uh el paso el paso
he was selling gum at the border
he took him home with me
he stuck around for a few years they
left me he went to new york and he got
mugged they told him
and then he got true and then he [ __ ]
came back and he had a girlfriend
long-legged she took the dog and the cat
he was heartbroken
so not only
the poor girl ain't even got the aspca
giving up the dog
he's already got a new girlfriend right
oh yeah i moved he's in love this
[ __ ] is depressed for a day he
goes to the chiropractor boom he's brand
new
and i don't know what that chiropractor
does to him i don't know i have no idea
you got to go to him dr mike the napoli
in pasadena is he he's right down the
street from the ice house you still go
to that he's amazing it's um incredible
i the dude is unbelievable dr mike the
napoli family chiropractic in pasadena
he is literally you could walk to him
from the ice house he's right down the
street from the ice house all right next
time on the ice house at 11 in the
morning yeah he'll be there
so he gets a new girlfriend now but not
that he gets a special on [ __ ] the
thing
he gets an agent the managers go on the
road and he picks up this girl you know
i know i know this [ __ ] guy he's a
latin lover
and over the holidays she gets hit by a
car her sister gets hit by a car and
jerry's all caught up and i had to call
him and say listen that's your
sister-in-law
it's all over you got [ __ ] going on call
the girlfriend and tell her you're
dumping her out there you can't even be
around somebody right here by the car
bad luck i took him to lunch i [ __ ]
met him you think i'm kidding i'm on a
real meeting
yeah i'm like dog you gotta run
just the fact that she's related to
somebody
she was drunk walking around and
somebody hit her in the alligator state
by the way how to go by the way i told
my girlfriend that you said that she
loved it she's dying laughing she's got
the best that the humor did she was she
was we're just dying
you were making you're cracking jokes
about the [ __ ] christmas like
all this stuff okay
you're walking around [ __ ]
[ __ ] gloomy gus you know what i'm
saying he said for christmas they need
to get a [ __ ] reflective sticker yeah
like a reflective suit you're outside at
midnight in florida walking around
looking for [ __ ] butterflies and [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is wrong with people oh god i
don't [ __ ] around dog you come you show
up and you get hit by a car i can't talk
to you for a little while a couple of
weeks of [ __ ] i go to the track i you
know i'm based on luck just to test the
waters you have to be safe my
girlfriend's the same way she's like i
don't have to do this [ __ ] why do i
gotta go [ __ ] be there
remember those days when you like when
you first start doing the road and you
would do those clubs that had the house
mc and you thought at the time like oh
this must be like a pretty badass gig
and then you realize it was just a road
guy who got bitter remember that it was
just a road guy who got bitter and said
[ __ ] i hate this i'm never going to go
to la [ __ ] out live in l.a for a month
they hate it and they just go to some
[ __ ] town with a funny boner and
improv and they're the house mc for like
seven or eight years that would always
happen you remember that it was you know
and remember i first thought oh this
must be like a prestigious title like i
didn't know any better you know and then
you realize oh okay this guy is just
bitter as [ __ ] and got beaten down by
comedy so bad
but he does he can't not do it so they
just become the house mc at like the
small little club there it's funny
because jerry and i worked
a lot of the b rooms sometimes together
and sometimes separate so we report to
each other
and the b rooms at that time
you know if i was 35 no [ __ ]
i was 42 we were working with guys that
were my age now
and they they had a family and their
wife left them yes and they were like an
aaa now and
now they're on the road selling
cassettes t-shirts frisbees
and you can't where do you live kid that
way oh you got to be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah everybody just kissing the way you
get a movie is by sucking it yeah
it's like no you don't actually no you
don't have to do any of that and even
then guys with my attitude then my
street [ __ ] vernacular
i would look at these guys and go first
off i i
understand that pain yeah it's just
tough that's a hard one a tough goal up
there and to attain it and sure and god
knows what they went through in l.a but
it's tough for her to
walk around wounded like that like i i
used to look at it because i know i know
for years i walked around more than
after the divorce after my mom died i
walked around [ __ ] wounded
but i didn't think you could ever get
that wounded from comedy oh man like the
wounded i got was three four days the
longest yard
the longest yard
uh wounded me because
i thought more would get out of it i
didn't focus on what i had done like in
the [ __ ] movie i'm a [ __ ] ex felon
you know what i'm saying like i'm racist
[ __ ] like i robbed houses and [ __ ] yeah
and all of a sudden they let me on this
set whoever trusts me and [ __ ] i'm just
feeling reynolds and michael yeah i'm
saying like and that doesn't make me a
better person but just the fact that i
had gotten on like made me [ __ ] uh
like something's gonna come out of this
i didn't look at it for what i had done
you know what i'm saying of course
something's gonna come out of this
somebody's gonna call me nobody ever
[ __ ] called right so that was a big
uh bitter point but i never got bitter
you get angry you get sad it [ __ ] at
you for a month you have a good set and
it all goes away well gone so it all
goes away you get a good set and
somebody likes you nuts
and it all goes away your brand [ __ ]
knew i remember you you called me i'll
never forget this is how you know like
we're like that you're like my the older
brother i never had you know like cause
you called me
the night that i got bounced from last
comic standing and you told me you said
look dude it's gonna feel like you got
hit in a place you never knew existed
but you also said
it's only gonna last about a week you
know that's it and you're going to be
fine and
i remember you told me he said the best
thing to do is just go to a spot
somewhere go to a spot for you know a
couple of nights in a row and you're
going to have that one home run and
you'll be like oh listen the people who
listen to this podcast i'm not phi beta
kappa
but i know about one thing recovery yeah
from recovery from getting beatens in
recovery right i know from physical
beatings to mental beatings to emotional
beatings right i know the recovery route
to all three of those beatings you know
the [ __ ] the beat you put a steak on
your eye hey
he's staying until the bruises disappear
the other [ __ ]
nobody knows you have bruises right
nobody knows you have bruises so they
don't know you know i know what times in
my life i had mental health issues that
i cleared up you know
you do there's a month you do 20 days of
blow in that month your mind goes
somewhere it didn't take me till after i
came out of that trance to understand
that you know the emotional [ __ ] that's
that's the long one i read a great
article in the new york times about
patent oswald if anybody knows what's
going on he said he'll never be 100
again it's the saddest thing yeah listen
you never think you'll be a hundred
percent because how bad you feel and
sure sure when you mourn a loss and
that's one of the worst ways i mean
there's no good way to lose somebody you
love but holy [ __ ] the way that happened
is just it's hard man i i every time i
see an article about him i see he's
doing well i know exactly where he's at
right and i pray and i know he's not
doing drugs which is good because
the drugs are temporary but they take
you somewhere else again they take it to
a deep spot again so now you're not
recovering from the drugs you're
recovering from the drugs and that
[ __ ] darkness that you saw for
[ __ ] a week
so i know all about this [ __ ] and
it doesn't last guys
it doesn't last
unless you let it absolutely
and there's no formula
it's not a dog it's not a cat it's not a
human being it's not a chick that licks
your balls with gasoline on it
it's not a guy who comes on your titties
it's not somebody who has money you
never know what the formula is and the
guilt comes right in front of you and
then you go wow
i'm i'm over this or at least i feel
with my mother
i can honestly tell you that there's
times i go to a dark place now and i
tear up
just thinking about it so that lets me
know i'm really not over it or maybe i'm
over a part of the same here
with my dad yeah but at the other side
of it
you know relationships yeah uh movie
disappointments you know i didn't go to
montreal i didn't think i felt all those
years my first five years here if it
wasn't for the stupid movies and the
commercials i booked
that put me on the map in a way like
because like i've said a thousand times
on this podcast you're a struggling
common kid until something happens that
they see you on tv and even if it's a
small thing even if you're in a
commercial you just bend over and go hey
it's my lucky day
people comedy bookers see that uh
assistants see that and they tell the
people oh i saw jerry in a commercial
the night and that's it not that you're
rich or you mean anything you could hit
you just
put the odds a little higher that you're
gonna have a career in this town what
about our our friend destiny barra like
i met him a few years ago i was thinking
about him today
i i met him a few years ago with you at
the coffee shop
and now he's about like i just looked at
his thing he's done like every tv show
and movie and now he's about to like
co-star on a show with felipe felipe the
kid works he has a great look he's got a
great goofy he's funny and he's a nice
guy he's a nice guy he's young you know
yeah you know all those guys you see him
now
and in 10 years you see some of them and
there's one or two guys that are bitter
every comedy thing has a bitter comic oh
god and you know and i prayed not to
become a lesbian you know what do you
know when i realized okay i don't want
to be this guy it was two things it was
the first guy who was the house emcee
and remember you know sometimes if you
knew if you knew the headliner if you
knew the middle right you would come in
and this house mc would walk up and they
would always introduce themselves with
look you know normally a headline but
they would always have an excuse built
in as to why they were the mc do you
remember that it was always and you're
like what dude you don't need to tell me
like i don't you know this just do just
go up it's fine like nobody's judging
you you know but they always have that
immediate like okay well here's my
excuse don't judge me i'm i promise you
i'm a headliner but you know [ __ ] and
then they start going off in this rant
about like the other one i thought okay
i don't ever want to do that and then
the one that really hit home was
when i was in el paso at the club el
paso was the place where i
saw i did a lot of work in el paso you
and i were very fortunate yes that bart
reed loved this as a feature act he used
to call me every six weeks and then he
let me stay two weeks one time he was
the best it was the best because he had
a condom you could it was in your
apartment for like a month sometimes
people come by and it was crazy and that
a pool yeah had a pool and it was around
the corner from a supermarket then on
friday so yucatan yeah
so you did a pound the blow you walked
down to that soup
it was next to an arby's that's where i
realized how bad arby's had become right
right
the arby's like a 98 down there hadn't
been in the rv since like the 80s it was
[ __ ] this meat that looked like oh
shitty dude they got shitty but el paso
you worked el paso there was
a lot of the michigan rooms
the buffalo rooms all the yoda rooms
are great the yoda runs the
uh 50 of the triple runs some of the
trouble runs were tremendous okay some
were awful but some are great those are
the runs where you bumped into
comics that were very my first run
ever
i started with a guy named david tribble
i was a host at one of his
nights and this is in the northwest
right this was in boulder in baltimore
well the broker was always open when
they started the comedy night they had a
magician who was an old guy
the broker was known for in those days
in boulder there was the
the friday afternoon club
excuse me had become one of the biggest
pickup places in the country playboy had
even put it in this place the hilton
harvest hilton or something in boulder
was on the biggest pickup places in the
country
and on fridays friday afternoon club you
saw cars lined up all around the wrapper
hall it was [ __ ] craziness you know
i don't even know what i'm talking about
you know can i tell you this real quick
uh
where i grew up in dallas i grew up in
the village apartment complex and there
was a tom thumb grocery store it's still
there but it used to be in this place
called old town shopping center it's
still all that's still there right but
that tom thumb made playboy's top five
places to get laid in america back in
the 80s because it was the grocery store
that all the college kids who went to
smu would go to so you would go there on
a friday or saturday night dude it was
like you're in a nightclub it was just
packed it was like tailgate parties
almost people hooking up it was
incredible so it's like funny you say
that but yeah i remember those places
existed back then it was like just deep
you you impossible not to get laid if
you go there so that was the kid one
yeah and the adult one was the broker on
wednesday night okay and they gave they
had a shrimp bar wow and then when i
first started going to the broker like
somebody i was married
and somebody said to me you want to go
for a drink i don't want i didn't know i
was selling cars yeah i just got another
halfway house i didn't really drink but
it would be nice you know like you work
late sometimes let's go and talk
business me and this guy sold the car
he took me to the broker one night and i
was blown away
like it was the cheesiest [ __ ] place
ever
you know guys wore cologne uh disco ball
if you went from five to seven they gave
away free shrimp so every mooch
and both of course bought a soda and
they could get free shrimp
like a salad bar a cheese bar let me
tell you something man that bar was
great sunday nights they had two movies
and a dinner for 15 bucks that's not bad
and [ __ ] that's great but they were
violating copyrights for some reason
something yeah yeah they're not paying
universal for this they stole a reel
from somewhere
they would just rent
but people would go down there with
blankets
it was the come on guys nobody does this
[ __ ] no more they would get hot cocoa in
the winter when it snowed so they had a
comedy night and i had well i was just
becoming a comedian
like it was like an episode of celia
cruz
on netflix it's in spanish it's [ __ ]
tremendous i'm up to episode 29 nice
nice and it's changed my life like it's
[ __ ] me up because i may remember the
cuban person that i have but anyway
going back to that i started comedy in
july and in august
in the paper they would put ads for
canada and both and i go what the [ __ ]
i'm a comedian that it wasn't no
comedian i'd been in states twice
i went to new york i came back and they
had a contest yeah and i went down there
anyway i want it and then the house
emcee was terrible so i told the manager
you see how many people came to see me
the other day i have like this every
tuesday what he didn't know was i was
selling valium right so i'd make people
come down there and buy videos like that
and they would give that's the way to do
a bringer
actually
that was hot illegal you want to buy it
you gotta
and i got in there and i became family
and you know i was 28
28 29 and i was just separated there was
waitresses
and i would talk to the waitresses and i
fell for one at first
i fell for one high god waitress those
are always the first love of our lives
and she had a boyfriend i'm trying to
win her from the boyfriend oh no you're
gonna steal her oh i was trying really
hard she was so beautiful and i remember
one night we were by a gate and she said
i can't do this with you anymore and i i
broke down and started crying like a
little girl i thought i was weak oh it
was right after my divorce i was dude
i've been there bro i've been there
january came and i hope it came out of
that a new stack of waitresses came in
out of college
and i started dating this one you wiped
your tears off oh my god i wiped those
teeth i told you you only get depressed
for like three or four days it's true
it's true and i was sitting at home this
is this is embarrassing to say a stack
of weeks i won the contest december 18th
i won the contest december 18th
and at that time they were home for
christmas vacation i had just graduated
and i had just seen a bunch of them and
then i didn't get the job till after
january
so here i am for 10 [ __ ] days sitting
in this house
i swear to god i got no reason to lie to
nobody i lived in a condo all right the
condo was up for sale there wasn't
a stick of furniture in this place well
just a cabinet yeah with a tv a vcr
upstairs
there was a towel it was a guy's
bathroom yeah my wife had been gone for
three months at this time okay
the bedroom was just a bed they even
took the box springsley jesus
i couldn't sleep up there because they
took the curtain i don't know about
curtains
they took the [ __ ] curtains wow
and i don't have to sleep downstairs it
was a [ __ ] nightmare all right so
this day these are the emotional
beatings you take god here i am single
i don't have my kid for christmas
you know i'm sitting there i'm doing
blow
i'm living like a doctor because i got
like eight credit cards left
so i was going to lodizio and getting 30
for lunch
30 for breakfast i was like oh you
should have seen me
signing tabs having a good old time
that's on me i got that's on me i got
this and then i [ __ ] was heartbroken
in one j i went over there on a tuesday
do comments i started talking all
waitress i'll tell you next time we
started talking talking talking talking
i saw the next tuesday we started
talking and then i went out for a drink
we did karaoke
you know she was fresh out of college
and i was like dirty and [ __ ] what are
you singing karaoke i busted out michael
jackson remember the time ooh
alligator it was an australian ball with
pool tables and that's where he went
yeah after the broker and i went up
there and sang and i could see she was
smoking cigarettes drinking i'm like i
got this you got this you got it and but
she was clean and soap but she only
drank okay and she didn't even smoke
cigarettes she only drank like she you
know she was trying to be a wild one
right so she was smoking i fell in love
with her she was a cute [ __ ] girl
so here i was the host she was a
waitress
i'd be there on tuesday nights but i was
in there every day for lunch on the arm
because she was the owner's daughter oh
so she'd tell me come for lunch i'll buy
you one so we're going to had the best
rice krispie treats beautiful in the
world they had a buffet and since i was
the king of swing i could mortalize and
dibble
forget about it but that was like
all my other comedian friends at that
time were really struggling for stage
time
but i had as much time on a tuesday
as i wanted to well that's great as a
young comic that's and every week you
had a right because every week the same
people came together all that tv show
better so you were forced to write
you don't it was hard what do you mean
better it was hard but it makes you
better
sunday i would sit in the apartment and
try to write try to write newspapers
from the week i would just try to write
local material
but that's okay you learned how to write
how to write you learn how to write it
man and i remember coming out one time
with two cups on my tits like
vogue and [ __ ] yeah
listen man i was a young comic i was in
love with this girl i was divorced i got
a new [ __ ] uh
you know that's great but whatever
[ __ ] lease in life yeah and uh
that was and i met stanhope there he was
a feature there the first time uh kermit
appio and ron
a lot of neat guys there the guy that
helped vinnie curdle write scripts that
was a town coordinator at the store in
the 70s i met him there when i came out
here it was like you remember me yeah
how are you oh my god you're here you
were the [ __ ] host you were terrible
like oh my god i left that going jesus
you're here you know and uh
it's great that's i was there for a year
and a half and i booked i pushed the
manager he went to the bookshelf nice
and i got fired that was the end of that
[ __ ] tour well you know in el paso
with my my big kind of like okay this is
what i definitely don't want to be was
we're working i was working with the
dude who you and i have
talked about on several occasions
i think you know who that is and he was
on the phone with uh you know the old
guy who used to run addison improv trey
right and this guy was on the phone with
trey and i'll never forget i'm still a
middle i'm still a kid i still don't
know what you know and i hear him going
yeah [ __ ] la [ __ ] i'm never gonna you
know what if they want me they know
where to [ __ ] find me they can come
find me and i thought oh you don't want
to be that guy because no one they're
they're getting like they're gonna go to
[ __ ] el paso just to scout this guy
like that's this isn't [ __ ] baseball
you know like they don't send [ __ ]
scouts out to all the clubs like that's
not how it works and that's why i was
like i don't want to be that chicken
[ __ ] guy who you know just gets so
bitter that they get afraid and they
have to just oh well okay i'm it's like
they want to jump on their own grenade
you know they're so afraid of hearing no
that they're like well [ __ ] it i'll just
jump on the grenade so i it just i can
you know like nobody can reject me if i
don't take a chance at anything it's
just i never wanted to be like that you
know it was interesting like the way you
cope with [ __ ] when my dad died
moving out here is what helped
right after he passed away i'm like [ __ ]
it it's time to go to la what am i just
wasting my i'm just spinning my wheels
here in texas it's time to move you know
that people of all ages listen to this
podcast you know
but it's really weird like to be young
and to make that jump yeah how important
that jump is sometimes
even if you just stick your head out
like a gopher on february 2nd
look around and go back home after nine
months
i did that the first time your friend
last year she came she saw it wasn't
funny she was here for a couple years
yeah she was here for a couple years and
i'm not mad at i don't get mad at those
people no she's killing it in boston
right now yeah some people go you know
what i could have done better at home
but at least you got out you had an
experience yes and i was telling uh
before the podcast started what you were
asking me where did i live and i said
snowmass
that we were talking about i broke into
a cheese shop one night
i was at a bar i was 19 years old guys i
still had the bug in those days you know
how some people drink and do stupid
things of course i would drink and steal
right i would go crazy now could you do
it sober or did you have to be did you
have to have a drink in here i mean like
like i would be home for a week and a
half yeah and to unbreak the
homesickness like i've broken all these
things down in my head
you know like i was addicted not to
drugs at that time right
excuse me i was a reefer head at that
time when i moved when i moved to
colorado the first time i understood
what it was to be a real hippie it's not
those guys with the long hair that stick
it's an attitude these guys
were laid back nothing bothered me i
never understood what laid back was
until i went to snowmass village the
first time in 1983 really
so i was telling these guys that one
night i had this bedroom like when i got
to
basalt
i moved into a room that had belonged to
somebody else that he had to go home
because it was an emergency in his
family so all i did when i got there was
take the sheets off flip over the
mattress wash the sheets and they were
mine that had become my bed
so when we moved out of it the kid came
back and took all his stuff so the
apartment i got with my buddy
basically had nothing
i mean nothing when we moved in there
there was a black and white tv a table
an oak table with a [ __ ] milk crate
under it a couch that stunk
and there was nothing and the rooms were
nothing
so i by first i put like a
a [ __ ] uh matt down and i put a sheet
over and i slept like a [ __ ] indian
like just on the floor yeah like bruce
lee and fist of fury under a tent and
[ __ ] like in your room and the apartment
was clean it was [ __ ] tremendous the
pain i mean it was uh creekside
apartments i think at the time and they
were [ __ ] pretty much new you know
and uh
his brother my roommate's brother also
from my neighborhood
was a carpenter on a job site that was
the biggest
building in snowmass village at the time
it looked like a battleship that's what
people called it they built a [ __ ]
battle ship up there
so one day i went to meet him and i go i
thought these things were being built
but they had already a condo that was
had the furniture the flowers the towels
the [ __ ] bath mats
something out of a [ __ ] magazine like
a model home like a model home so i go
in there i see this [ __ ] like an ikea
display yeah i go home i tell jim i go
jim i saw something very interesting
today he goes what i go you know the way
your brother works they got apartments
[ __ ] got furniture
he goes joey we can't do that
you don't have to do nothing let me go
snoop around yeah
sunday night i went up there
the door was open
damn like the realtor left the door open
i went in put the light on i took
everything i could i put in a circle
including a mattress
and a [ __ ] box break
and i made three or four clients that
today i could never do it no and i did
it between nine and like two in the
morning wow
with [ __ ] wheelbarrows and then he
finally got up he was drunk he finally
got up
and he helped me carry like nobody woke
up none of that [ __ ]
there was nobody in the building there
was all the construction yeah and they
didn't go like apartment to apartment
looking no no no no they was they didn't
know and i went into the [ __ ] one
room and it was all the tools
and jimmy's like let's rob tools
i'll never forget he got like a ball
stuck it in and put his feet up against
the thing and he started pulling back
and it just broke and he landed on his
back he's like
but we went and furnished our whole
apartment it went like we went from
[ __ ]
zero to a hundred pounds batman from an
air bed we did a full display
we had everything a new couch
and finally the brother knocked on the
door and then he goes hey what's going
on
i was telling me it wasn't you guys and
he came in and started laughing trust me
i was thinking of doing it
just throw me a lamp and i won't say no
that was the end of that we had all this
new furniture that's kind of on them to
build an apartment not have it be
completed and furnish it empty that
you're asking for that to [ __ ] have
no security with joey is around 1983
you're crazy come on you couldn't leave
a nickel down without me clipping it
i was a clip from
81 i started clipping heavy like
let's face it i clipped for years like
when i was a young kid little things
bicycles and [ __ ] i knew [ __ ] was
clipped and i just turned the other way
how easy was it for you to spot a mark
back then to be like oh that i could get
that place like i'll [ __ ] yeah i could
get them
was it like a couple of pass buys was it
could you do it on one sitting like you
just see a store for a little bit and go
jesus they don't do anything in that
back room like i went crazy i saw a
movie called thief
yeah in 1981 and that's it well that was
it was it like a how-to the movie was it
literally like
okay when i was a kid
and 205 west 88th street two other
families lived in that building that
knew my mom okay i know my mom well
right one was this black lady who was
like a seamstress oh [ __ ]
in manhattan and they drank at night i
forget what her name was
she had like a uh a mulatto last night
yeah sure but the other two of the
building was a lady named chief lachina
okay she was a cuban chinese chick
and i was about
five maybe okay and through me became
tight
and i didn't know what monkey so you
know when you're five you don't care
what people do no right because i got to
the point where my mom would go what do
you want to do tonight i go i'm gonna
all the chicken the light and go
upstairs and hang out with monkey
and for the first couple of times
mongito would be in the bedroom and the
china would talk to me
and there's one time i went up there and
finally mondito goes let him in and i
went in there mongita had one of those
operations with the the spinning wheel
oh with the [ __ ] the heavy duty
yeah yeah and he would take uh
those things that for for to measure
spark plugs
okay in those days and he turned him
into keys
and he asked him what do you do and
finally he told me he was a burglar
and he would bring me chains and little
rings and [ __ ] and my mom you know
everybody knew he was a professional
[ __ ] burglar that's what he wants in
fact years later he went to jail for rob
mcmahon koch he's the one that wrote no
way this guy was the real deal
so i didn't see him for years after that
but him and her broke up or something
but
i always had that vision of this dude
was so cool he was a thief so right i
never told my mom and [ __ ] but right
away i started clipping nickels at the
bar and rolls recorders and my mom would
ask me every time you come around
something disappears
i had a problem with that too as a kid
taking some money always always oh man
always and i wouldn't take it from my
mother's person i got to be like eight
or nine right that's when he got ballsy
like i can do this after the first time
i think she left my hands on fire oh
[ __ ] like she [ __ ] held her with a
lighter and she was like listen
i knew it was you
you got the kiss and then oh i set you
up like a [ __ ] you dumb [ __ ] i
left that 20 waiver and you clipped it
and that was it
she knew i was clipping 20s from the dry
cleaner
and again she would look at me and go so
wait a second mysteriously we lost to
20. mysteriously you found the gi joe
behind a [ __ ] garbage can in the
bronx that's brand new only you can find
the brand new gi joe behind the garbage
can
that's great you know i did a club in
honey in orange county one time and i
remember the door guy i was staying i
was after hours selling my cd all that
[ __ ] and the guy was taking his
flashlight i was like what are you doing
dude and he goes oh because he was the
bouncer because do you know how many
people dropped 20s when they're paying
for drinks he was just right by the bar
where the stools were and he probably
made like 400 bucks almost a night on
the hot nights there because people just
take up they get drunk they start paying
for their cash just comes falling out
and they don't even notice that they've
dropped like 60 70 dollars just right
there it's crazy man it's crazy
yeah so my my whole thing with thievery
started then then i was okay and then
when i got to north bergen that was it
those kids were animals they just got
they were like they kind of we were
young kids we were already like giving
out terrorists we were already savages
that kind of enabled you to keep so we
mixed all of us little savages together
there's a story i tell about raul
raul was a kid who moved across the
street from your house not up the corner
not three houses up the block there was
a house across from 35 15 giving that
terrorist i showed lee
right across the street from where i
grew up there was a [ __ ] house right
there yeah and one day me and my little
[ __ ] friends are down the corner we
see the moving truck
and we look at each other and we go
there it is
there's the first score we're going to
break into wow and they [ __ ] went in
dumped a bunch of stuff and we counted
the guys
they didn't hit the block and we were
already in the back you're kicking in
the window guess what i take the stereo
with the speakers okay i don't know
nothing about nothing
so they they just got a house and the
first
the first trip the first load they
brought
there was like five of us that went on
going and then just cleaning it up
and i took the speaker and the stereo
okay
the next day i get up there there's
[ __ ] cops outside they're asking
questions
even then i don't know
so wait you broke into the house instead
of just taking it from the truck well no
because they left the truck they would
they empty out the truck and went to
pick it up
they dropped the first load they take
the truck
i gotta be 12 i got to be maybe tops no
no no i was 12. if they if they'd been
dumb enough to leave the truck there
y'all would have taken the truck oh
you're right yeah
somebody wouldn't learn how to drive it
crazy
we could have found somebody
this is like our first junior heist we
take the [ __ ] i take the stairs that's
not a bad [ __ ] heist for the dude
yeah but guess what happens
the family moves in and it's a kid named
rahul oh no and raul was a serious
basketball player he was puerto rican
from the bronx okay
and he was tremendous we needed this kid
on the team and the first day in school
he's like i moved in and somebody broke
into my [ __ ] house and took my stereo
so now i became friends with raul oh no
who would come over for dinner and [ __ ]
how would you explain it dodge can't go
to my bedroom
did your mom ever say why don't you guys
go to your bedroom no she you told her
that right like
man what would what would your mother
have done had she seen y'all doing what
happened was
later on then my mom and their mom
became friends right
and then it got really [ __ ] up so i
told my mom that somebody else had
stolen and i bought it from oh that
sound bad yeah did she believe it yes
okay okay and that was because we had a
friend hedy lamenka
alamenko was a dude that was five foot
one
cuban had no disregard of respect for
nothing oh man if there was something
that you left for a minute it's his it
was eddie's and the problem with that he
was he was lightning
in real life like you couldn't catch him
jesus like you couldn't catch him
there's no way he could bust him taking
[ __ ] yeah wow so eddie would come to
your house
once a day with something the jewelry
store hey look what i got boxes i
remember one time we robbed a box of
condoms we went to get ice cream and
we're walking back and there's a
pharmacy
we don't even know what i use a condom
hey i bet you but everybody got condoms
in the neighborhood everybody had two
condoms in that wallet i got my wallet
we hadn't felt like a king and i never
saw a tit at that time in my life
walking around with a condom in my
[ __ ] wallet oh that's great jesus
yeah and then there was a kid next to me
valentine pharaoh
and he was a [ __ ] professional
bicycle klepto
who i adored i called him about a year
ago and then he called me back i [ __ ]
with me for about a week yeah um
was it just pop change could he get him
team was you
with bicycles this is before the
computer oh yeah okay valentine nor
drank nor smoked yeah he was a [ __ ]
nerd like if you pulled up in front of
valentin's house and just had a
conversation with him with a bicycle
he'd find something wrong with your
bicycle and call you an idiot
you're walking around with a stupid
[ __ ] bicycle you should oil that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] chain your [ __ ] [ __ ]
something wrong with a spoke and he
finds it and then he'd go how come he
don't have a [ __ ] bar how you gonna pop
wheelies i gotta sit here behind the
back give me three hours late and he
come and install the [ __ ] bar damn
while you were talking to you he was a
genius he was one of those nerds yeah i
can't say what he does now but now i saw
what he became right he was one of those
nerdy dudes and then
one day i said something to him like oh
you're looking for a handlebar i saw a
bike tied up
and he's like what do you think can i
steal it and i didn't i thought that it
belonged to somebody that was selling it
like on 39th street and he went and
stole it wow and like a day later he
took the handle bars put it on his
bicycle and he built another bicycle
from that bicycle they came looking for
that bicycle and he had it right there
that's why i saw numbers even though
it's in my mind
he was a great painter he taped
everything he took everything off all
that metal he took off he polished it he
[ __ ] nailed down the serial number
and put another serial number down he
was a genius he was a genius at 12. and
he was a speed demon he would get on the
bicycles and go up to the top of the
hill and shoot down and [ __ ] trust me i
can't go into how many bad things i did
too
i got him on a putt-putt one night over
the holidays you know
yeah
yeah and he [ __ ] hit black ice and
but the seat wasn't screwed in and also
he looked right at me
i could live to be a hundred oh and i
will never forget that night that's
amazing he did probably the thing was
like a 50cc yeah but richie vanicek was
another nerd with glasses that used to
go hunting and he revved that engine up
to like a 75 cc and it was like
christmas you want to water bro i'm good
i'm good thank you it was like christmas
and we traded motorcycles
and [ __ ]
great man but that was i knew a lot of
kleptos yeah you know it's funny when i
went to colorado i had a friend that was
sending me stolen stuff lee couldn't get
rid of it
what do you mean you couldn't get right
now if i came to you lee and i said
league guess what
i got a box of [ __ ] i got a truckload
of microphones out there like okay every
time you
start a podcast you can sell them
microphones
that cost lee's not from that
environment he would not buy him
lee would not understand nowadays yeah
yeah because he always though this is
different are those marked can can they
trace it back to me
yeah when i was growing up it was very
you would walk into people's homes and
some of these parents would say excuse
me what size shirt are you
what's the matter large hold on what i'm
saying
mildred bring out those shirts
they start putting shirts on you and the
family the father the salesman
i grew up with a family specifically
that i would go to their home
to place bets
and every time i go to their home
there was always something you walked
out of there now you owe the guy 90
dollars
i went in there [ __ ] house
when i tell you guys
it was he couldn't close it like from
all the stolen [ __ ] in there and he
would go in there looking and go i just
got him a week ago hold on he'd open it
up and start pulling [ __ ] out of there
all over the street you know and there'd
be [ __ ] all over the street let me find
those pair of sneakers for you give me
15.
put on the arm come by just when you're
gonna come by with my money next week
okay put them on they look nice on you
not only was he a thief like he got him
from somewhere somebody would dump a
load on him
but he knew how to dress you right like
he got those black pants with that brown
pair look at that listen i got some
black pants you're gonna look like
[ __ ] al capone when you're
like 13. you're like what the [ __ ] i'm
buying pants in the house
do you saw that eddie alvarez area
helwani walk remember he walked by a
store with the fake nike shirts and then
he said this guy at the store had been
there forever just like stolen fake
necking shirts
but back then there was really like
i remember because i you know i was i
was a very little kid back there but i
still have the memories of like being
like 10 years old nine years old family
does a road trip to vegas right and the
minute you get near the strip eight
dudes were trying to sell my uncle a
gold watch a gold chain you know what i
mean it was just this back then
right i don't know am i wrong it just
seemed like it was just the wild west
for that kind of [ __ ] where people would
bootleg any [ __ ] thing any handbag
like my aunt was a she taught a high
school all mexican high school in dallas
dude you go to the parking lot and after
school every day from like 81 to 87 it
was kids selling uh handbags that were
either stolen or fakes right all that
[ __ ] just that's all it was 24 7. it was
interesting how there was just no like
it was just kind of a thing and you'd be
like [ __ ] are they gonna get busted and
they never got [ __ ] busted at least
that you saw they were just there every
friday night after school they would
just be sitting there trying to sell
[ __ ] when school ended it was crazy
i uh never
really met
hijackers until i got out of north
bergen and came back
and
they didn't sell you this stuff they
dumped the whole load somewhere you know
but it's funny how when my mom had the
bar when i was a kid
italians would come in there with
dresses
women's shoes sneakers once they get to
know you yeah they know they'll look at
you before they leave they already come
prepared mm-hmm you look like you're six
you know
some of them should show up with the
[ __ ] thing there's a movie called
family business
with uh sean connery yes i remember this
broadcast matthew brock yeah yeah yeah
and uh cause it doesn't happen and
dustin's right okay yeah and and every
scene in three other scenes in that
movie
a guy with stolen stuff shows up
and it's [ __ ]
perfect at how is happening in new york
in the mid 70s because my mom used to go
to a bar
before we went to a track i was like
[ __ ] six right and i still remember
that guy like in my head what he looked
like like you know he was selling
watches
but this guy in this movie did it
perfect the first scene he comes in and
sean connery's drinking with matthew
broderick at the bar
and he walks in hey how you doing what's
going on oh this is paulie's go i know
you're dead what's going on how you
doing what do you got tonight oh i got
five again
three hundred dollars up and down
broadway i got them for 90 years oh
that's fabulous and he goes like this
like it goes i got them up and down
broadway they go for 300
i got them right here tonight for 75
bucks and right away he goes what size
he
and he gives him the shoes and by the
way he's already done 90. that's just
the way it is you unders you bought it
you took it he knew and if you didn't
have the money he was fine he'll catch
you next we'll get you next week he'll
get you next week because he's coming
back with his suit right but you know
that these and they were for you to have
these shoes they were really 300 plus
tacks
he's getting right there for 75 [ __ ]
dollars think about that like you were
getting the best sale of your life and
then you look at the other guy and go
what are you at nine yeah i got you i
got you i got this [ __ ] it was [ __ ]
beautiful then he shows up at the wake
the dude that owns the bar
dies and this [ __ ] there's a
thousand cops in the room gangsters and
he's sure he walks and he goes oh
look at all the boys are here tonight
just like this and also two little
[ __ ] thugs
jackets and he's like how you doing boys
i got it he's like how you guys doing
all right this jacket this is a [ __ ]
italian
it goes for 800 all over the east side i
got it right here for 200 cash what size
are you 42 gotcha i mean he always had
your number and then you see him later
on at the [ __ ] when they dump the
ashes
he's carrying like a load of tvs
[ __ ] five floors
those guys are relentless those guys
wouldn't exist out here you know
somebody would called the cops on you
know who got you know who replaced him
and that took this is what i really
think
the modern day version of heist guys are
the people who do the storage auctions
who own those [ __ ] storage facilities
and then the people can't pay them and
now that shit's theirs and they just
sell it like that is how is that any
different really you know what i mean
it's just a legal way of robbing people
is to say here put your [ __ ] in storage
yeah 80 bucks a month oh whatever you
don't need just put it in storage and
then people forget they don't make
payments then they lose all that [ __ ]
and they just sell it they just auction
it there's even a [ __ ] tv show about
it with that [ __ ] storage wars you
know like people i mean that's like
that's that modern day heist you ever
lose the storage i did my mom did i was
so pissed all my concert t-shirts were
in a box and i was like oh it was like
come on and it was it was good
lifting bench
i had a [ __ ] mattress that was
tremendously comfortable how many months
did they give you to pay rent i paid it
for six months
and i called i didn't [ __ ] know the
game i thought you could you know i was
trying to chuck and josh joe that shit's
like vegas dog those those storage
classes are like vegas i didn't [ __ ]
know the house always wins with storage
they always get you dude i've never
heard of a good story with a story
someone putting [ __ ] in stores they
always end up like ah i fell behind [ __ ]
it and then all your shit's gone it's
just i'm telling you dude that's the
modern heist that's why i'm never gonna
do this [ __ ] i'll just throw it away
i'll sell it i'll give it to a [ __ ]
one of my nephews one of my cousins
something but that storage [ __ ] you're
just asking it you're asking to be
somewhere in loreno right now there's
some [ __ ] walking around with my
nirvana concert t-shirt my faith no more
my oktong baby like they got all that
[ __ ] it's oh man
it's not the worst when you
i had to start from scratch
two or three [ __ ] times the one time
after they you were laughing at house
mc's i was a house i'm seeing miami for
[ __ ] yeah but you weren't a better
comic you were just starting i was
that's it wasn't starting i was here
already oh okay and my car got towed my
apartment got told oh there you go yeah
you have no choice and i go joke
whatever the manager can you give me
1500 for four weeks because i don't know
if i can do that yes you can you can do
it he did it and i went down him and
that was a
what's that store that they always have
sales
i know what you're talking about joe or
something yeah what do they call those
[ __ ] stores
[ __ ]
christmas they're popular as [ __ ] they
got three t-shirts it's the men's
clothing place no they got everything
they got women's clothing too target
no no no no no no well anyway
they have this store in the heart of
[ __ ] miami and coconut grove
like it doesn't belong and it's two
floors
and i would go in there and get
and here's the other thing that they had
clothes that are heavier
that we could wear out here but you
can't wait you'll melt if you wear that
so it was amazing i got these deals so i
went in there after i had no clothes get
a velour track suit for 20 months
i got a whole [ __ ] wardrobe yeah they
threw in the socks bam
i was brand new after four weeks in
miami
food talking spanish but you came back
though that's the difference so those a
lot of those house mcs are the lifers
who they get so disillusioned and they
get so bitter and you know the guy i'm
talking about he wasn't a house emcee
but it's like this thousand listen man
let's pretend i would have came out here
and the [ __ ] wouldn't have gone the way
i thought right and all those years of
traveling there's one comedy club owner
that i clipped with always yes
and go listen guy
i'm going to buy i'm not doing too well
yeah i know you got that extra comedy
kind of on the back you used to [ __ ] the
weights right let me move in there let
me get my life together you bring a
waitress i'll get out of your way
writing class with young comics teach
defensive driving defensive driving and
whatever and i'm and then the weeks you
don't want me i'll pick up around texas
so i'll pick up around arizona or
michigan
listen there's a couple types of comics
and after the journey i've taken i
respect every single one because you
have a choice on what to do late for
everybody no
new york gay for [ __ ] everybody but
and i will say this to to go against my
point you you have to i still you can't
get mad at the fact that those guys are
still doing it at least at least they
didn't throw in the towel at least
they're actually still doing comedy i
was gonna ask that why i mean it's not
i'm not saying that they should give up
on if it's their dream but if they
dude it's it's like it's like coaching
like i remember my
my algebra teacher in high school
junior year algebra was an old football
coach and he would just sit there and
draw plays while we were all taking a
test and be like what do you i would ask
like what are you doing he goes man pay
some coaching ain't never leaving your
blood if you're a coach you're a coach
for life same thing with stand up it
never leaves you like there's no way any
guy who's been a stand-up comic for more
than a couple of years is ever not going
to sit there and write jokes and want to
do it like it just doesn't tell you
let's pretend
you come out here
you meet a girl you have a child right
now
you're doing okay it's a comic you're a
warm-up on a tv show [ __ ] hey you do
some spots at the end
some club is higher you got a night here
at night there you do the spanish clubs
with willie and philippe and [ __ ] you
make a little money
you know what man and one day you go you
know what we don't want to live here no
more yeah i respect that guy too because
he's got a [ __ ] family right you know
maybe he gets a great deal in arizona
his wife gets a great job a lot of guys
i open i started with denver
they ended up having children and what
they did was they got a job yeah and
then they did comedy they did those
rooms and but they understood where they
were
they knew their place
this is what i'm going to do with my
life i'm going gonna keep my day job my
family needs insurance and they were
happy but at night my wife knows i do
three nights a week out i come here on
tuesdays and see the boys i go to
mckelvie's on thursdays and those dudes
are happy yeah man because you know
where the [ __ ] you stand right you know
and you know it's it ain't no but they
put you in the casket right right look
at ronnie dangerfield it ain't over do
they put you in a casket
that's the other thing that people never
really
you could be [ __ ] uh somebody was
telling me what's his name story junior
soprano
he hadn't worked for years yeah and
listen here he goes he's in the
godfather too yeah he was in the
godfather yeah you know so
you never [ __ ] know what any you
ain't over until it's over i think joe
pesci was a failed singer he was working
his singing career didn't take off and
he was working at a restaurant do you
remember that story yeah he was working
at a restaurant it's like the the what
do they call the guy the maitre d the
one hey yeah in new york and he gets a
phone call it's de niro and scorsese ask
him to be in raging bull and he thinks
it's a friend pranking him so because i
[ __ ] you and he hangs up on him and they
call back they're like this is really us
we want you to come read for this like
you never did i ever tell you um the
bill hicks story when when he was doing
danger fields for the first time um do
you remember it was that girl sandy
daperna do you remember her i know him
in the name okay so she used to manage
him way back when right and this is
always tell any young comic who's ever
like you know that when they get bummed
out about having a bad set none of that
[ __ ] matters no because okay so bill
hicks goes to new york for the first
time and she's his manager and she knows
remember that guy he he managed
everybody from like drew carey to
foxworthy mussina remember him like yeah
yeah okay so he at the time i guess he
knew a bunch of people in new york and
she said it was it was either him or his
brother right and she goes look i want
this kid bill you know he's i think he's
a really funny comic he's amazing i want
to get him you know just kind of get his
feet wet in new york city i'll give him
a night at dangerfields we'll call him
we'll put him up and he goes up bill
hicks and he bombs his ass off just
[ __ ] bombs and he goes he leaves the
club he goes to the ho he goes to a pay
phone and he calls sandy at like two in
the morning and he's crying he's like
look you stuck your neck out for me and
i let you down and i'm so sorry i i just
i can't up and she goes look it probably
wasn't as bad as you thought just you
know go to your hotel room get you know
get some sleep i'll call the guy in the
morning you know i'm sure it'll be fine
he goes to this hotel room sleeps it off
she calls the dude the next morning she
goes look uh you know i heard my guy had
a bad set and he goes no no he didn't
have a bad set he had the worst set that
anybody has ever had in this club that's
how bad he was and then she starts to
apologize
she's like oh my god and he goes no no
rodney loved him
that was it rodney dangerfield happened
to be sitting at the back of his own
[ __ ] room saw him and was like [ __ ]
this audience that guy like and that was
it that he got him on his hbo special
that kick-started his career granted he
you know he wasn't as big in
america as he was in england but none of
his career would have happened had it
not been for the worst set of his
[ __ ] life so it's amazing how i
remember you told me this way back when
as long as you're still on stage you're
in the fight as long as you still go up
and perform comedy you're still swinging
you still have gloves on and you haven't
been knocked out yet and it's you're
absolutely right when you told me that
and that's that story is like proof
positive that like if there's any
comedian who's listening i know you got
a lot of comedian fans or comedians
don't ever get discouraged by a shitty
set because you never know what the [ __ ]
could be because we're going to have a
million of them and you never know
what's going to happen like could you
imagine the best set of your the worst
out of your life ends up being what what
gives you a better i mean it happens
dude
well because somebody sees your point of
view yeah that's all i hate this season
he had a voice he wasn't he wasn't a
dumb he didn't have any he had he wasn't
doing hacky [ __ ] he had his own voice he
had his own style and rodney danger
feels like no yeah this guy's great i
don't [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] if the
crowd's not laughing this guy's amazing
yeah he's doing my you doing my young
comedian special you know i always tell
people i learned lessons from criminal
lessons right and it's very hard to
explain it lee's catching on over the
years he giggles at night sometimes we
stay and smoke a number and
i'll never forget say lawrence hmm san
lawrence is one of my all-time favorite
jewish people
and cylons did those camps like that
type of scam and
when he took you when you fell or
whatever you did you got hit by the bus
or whatever [ __ ] you
the next day he took it to the hospital
then he took it to a [ __ ] lawyer
right right
and as soon as he you know you went to
the lawyer and the lawyer started giving
you paperwork what doctors you're going
to see neurologists and what they
basically were doing running up bills
the more bills the more money you get
okay and they tell you and you're like
so when do i get my 30 000 likes
this is a job
this is a job but they said something
that always stuck with me
you got to punch it every day yeah
yeah
okay then something
[ __ ] with me about that they go the
work is punching in i don't forget how
they phrased i'm sorry i'm a little high
yeah yeah i don't know he went deep in
the murky world
but he was at the end of the day this is
just about punching it yeah he goes the
more you punch in the more money we're
gonna get the more you punch in and it
hit me weird
and that was the first time that got me
and then the second time it got me was
when i bumped into [ __ ] slash in the
riviera i got no reason to lie to nobody
i had three dollars in my pocket wow i
had cigarettes and water in my room
puddle water in those days i couldn't
even afford the thing ah i couldn't even
have the deposit for the [ __ ] phone
like rogan would have to like be
embarrassed the riviera paid me 200
bucks for the weekend jesus for two
shows at midnight it was a [ __ ]
and i went with joe and i'll never
forget that i was walking around from
the oxygen
it was like some type of convention like
okay comic books or t-shirts trying to
keep your ass away
i asked him what happened with axel he
goes you know right now you're broke and
you're struggling he goes but remember
these times
because
these are the times they're gonna
justify later on when you're getting big
checks
this is so you don't lose your mind
because that's what happens when people
don't put in the work they lose it they
lose it later on because they know they
didn't put in the work
i knew for a fact that if i punched in
which opposite of that means getting on
stage right at any level it could be a
50 set when i first got into comedy
everybody wants you to be this big money
earner i didn't look at it that way i
looked at it as what are you paying for
this room 50 bucks okay lee what are you
paying for your room 65 in the dinner
remember those days 60 and three drink
tickets [ __ ] you they were there 75 and
three drink tickets you know my first 50
spot i thought it was a rock star i'm
like oh my god that's it i got 50 cash
and then you stop making 100 a week now
it's 400 a month
then the next month you make an extra
gig 500 of them right now you're in the
game
because you kept your no
not low let me ask this do you remember
the first time you got back-to-back
weeks how crazy that felt remember that
you were just like [ __ ] hey like i
[ __ ] i really this is it's real isn't it
like it's about to go down right like
this is real like i think i'm gonna oh
they're awesome people yes they always
do that was the best [ __ ] feeling man
that's that's a good point there that's
that's great like
just keep punching it you have to you
have to that's it that that's the secret
that all these [ __ ]
dumb things because when somebody tells
you
i want to be a doctor once i take you
seven years you look at it like [ __ ]
from here to eternity of course you know
we all look at stuff like it's a
distance i'll never do 10 years in
prison [ __ ] people do it all the time
and they come out and they join a band
and they get that
and they're back bitched next you know
they're going on i don't know what
you're talking about i've been here all
night
you know the whole [ __ ]
i remember there was this comedian in
dallas great guy named dave little super
funny dude he's still around you know
he's just a doubt he's you did the road
for forever and he we pulled me aside
one day when i was a kid because i was
one comic was bitching it was a showcase
room in dallas and this dude was
bitching he was a new guy just came in
and he was mad that they weren't paying
him for a spot right and this guy dave
pulled me saying because you see that
guy you don't ever want to be like that
he goes if you're if you're trying to if
you're doing this just to make money
leave right now get because you know
that's not because you just have to want
to do it you have to want to be good at
it and then you'll get a paycheck don't
worry it doesn't matter fifty dollars
twenty two dollars twenty five dollars i
didn't look at it that way i remember
putting it down in notebooks yeah like
when i first moved to la i put down
every penny i made
and all those little felipe rooms and
rosario rooms and those you know those
rooms paid so many bills
gosh so many coke bills electric bills
and [ __ ] let me give some shout outs
here real quick
uh
executive function oh [ __ ]
tal more de
junior
cosmic timelessness
cocaine tamales making a comeback
the nut man
brett baker
said mark zero
and peter mandy bar are you kidding me
or what
lee how you feeling over there is this
mafia game [ __ ] downloaded or what i
think it probably is yeah jesus christ
two hours to download the game
i thought you popped in this like a cd
there were the days it just cost a
quarter you just put it in a quarter and
it was ready to go
you just pop in that token
at the arcade and you're ready to go
what do you got going on tarzan nothing
much man same old [ __ ] working on
another hour you know age is still
sending out yeah yeah doing a i'm in
claremont this weekend at the flappers
and then i mean i mean you're all
stomping girls i'll be at laughs in
seattle uh november fourth and fifth
headline tommy you don't know me yeah
when you get the seattle dog anybody ask
you something like that guy from london
i swear
i mean one more minute any good chinese
food up there that you that might still
be around 20 years yeah [ __ ] that's true
yeah 20 [ __ ] years
there was two places that were throwing
heat in seattle but eating that time for
me
i couldn't find the negro oh but i did
find soup okay noodles yeah and the
shrimp and lobster sauce
that would kick in the ball sack and
take you right there i understand
two places i found in both places made
them with prawns
one place by the old improv okay by the
market yeah yeah that fish market yeah
yeah this is 20 years ago sure sure
there was on when you came out of the
market you crossed the street and you
make a right on that street down and it
was in there it was a small joint they
had a creamy it was different than okay
you get in boston and stuff like that
lee
that's what i've been thinking about
lately i'm gonna go on an extreme diet
from now until i get to boston the first
night i'm gonna go get pork fried rice
and shrimp and lobster sauce they make
it with that brown
[ __ ]
boston shrimp it's dipped in [ __ ]
dead bodies out there yeah my dad used
to get that i never tried it i forgot to
ask you how did the special go man the
special was great yeah good good good
good for what i've done for what i could
do yeah you know the first uh i've been
watching the the clip
you know when you're there you're under
the ether sure you have a good time the
energy was great you know the second
show when i came out i appreciate all
the people that went
and uh
when i watched it yeah it was what i
expected that's awesome man they still
got to chop it up and put this
sound and all that stuff
it was an interesting experience did you
use uh did you use a cue card or
anything like that or did you remember
at all i didn't you know made dawg yeah
i went out there with a plan and then
for the second show i bombed the first
show so i had to switch it up yeah and i
[ __ ] went and then really gave me the
energy that they
you know you realize that the energy is
six six quarters of the back right i'm
saying when when in the set process do
you abandon the plan is it like are you
it all varies it all just depends i mean
like it you know you could panic and say
[ __ ] it after the first joke and and go
off i mean it all depends right and you
can tell with the crowd what they're
going to be into or not like yeah it's
but yeah i mean like my the one i did uh
with gabe the special it was one night
we had there wasn't even two shows it
was one show that i had to tape and and
fluff was like and i was scared shitless
but it was a nayaka up in new york and
uh
and i remember thinking like [ __ ] i i
don't know if i'm gonna be able to get
through and right as it's okay all right
you're up you know i hear you know
they're they're getting ready to bring
me up on the stage and it was literally
we had it was
one [ __ ] show it was a nine o'clock
show that was all that we had to tape it
was just one show and i'm like okay i
can do this one take one cut there was
no stop it we literally did the whole
[ __ ] thing in one you know it was
just one that four cameras right but it
was all one thing i was like [ __ ] it
let's do it i was scared shitless and
i'm walking out in to go up on stage and
i see joe de stefano mikey d's older
brother who looks just like mike just
like mike and i was when i saw him all
the fear it was like
i thought it was it was like mikey had
just walked in he gave jerry gives you
this big hug and i was like oh okay i'm
ready and it just went it was dude it
was incredible like it uh knock on wood
it's gonna be on a streaming service uh
in about a month or two so coming to a
theater day yeah yeah yeah how are you
feeling cocksuck you ready for another
start for the weekend sure let's keep
you alive and kicking this show you're
falling asleep you're going into the
trash
what are you going to go home and eat
what am i going to do what do you got
over there i got a i got some cold cuts
i think oh look what kind of coconuts
you got surprised me turkey and
pepperoni
where do you get them from i oh joey
turned me on to a new ralph's oh which
one was it it was great yeah oh my god
how's the parking over there cuz
it looked like it could be kind of tight
but when we went it was fine what time
did you go
i think we went like middle of the
afternoon are you talking cold water
with it no i like cold water
i'm a cold water witch i like the guy
what i'm saying you know who's actually
got not bad cuts is that john's that's
right there by us
the magnolia and laurel canyon dude the
cold cuts aren't bad they're not bad man
do they have humans
i don't know if they have that they all
right what do you get what do you get i
got there once and maybe i got the wrong
one but i didn't like it what did you
get in rounds you got doom i got
borsette poison dude morrison they got
boards that the one they had there that
it was [ __ ] unreal was this garlic
and herb uh peppered turkey [ __ ] man
that was a [ __ ] i like my turkey plant
all right yeah
i put all that [ __ ] on it i put all
these pepper little mayonnaise
shredded lettuce on the back [ __ ]
i see the role i'm back with you dude
you know with a slice of [ __ ] swiss
cheese have you been to roma's italian
deli that's right up lancashire
roma's oh trimmer how are we going this
is the inception dude that [ __ ] i
went to the place you know it's good
when the owner has three pictures of him
and sinatra hanging out like that's like
okay this is the place yeah that's
that's [ __ ] good man it takes balls
to go up there
that's a [ __ ] up part of town oh god i
go there all the time i just went after
about a year when i first moved up here
and i discussed somebody turned me on to
it and i started going in they got a
tremendous lunch bag oh there's italian
sandwiches it's a 565 for a soda a
sandwich
a salad two sizes you get [ __ ] the
roasted peppers yes and the macaroni
salad it's like i'm in ashwas yeah it's
like i'm in harsh ways jersey oh i need
mr hashmate dripping hair and yeah
it's got rest assault
it's so good that place man [ __ ] it's
good it's cheap as [ __ ] dude you're
right
six dollars you get a [ __ ] meal it's
man that place is good roma's is good
but you're right it is sketchy [ __ ]
going
over there they got that place next door
it's so explosive yeah
they got everything in how are they
going there you know the place i'm
talking about right next to it yeah you
got this place it's like a building and
they've got everything that's the car
stereo speakers a [ __ ] fire suit they
got everything
speak [ __ ] he applies i guarantee you
they own a storage unit somewhere and
they're not i mean they're taking [ __ ]
to people they're selling hot [ __ ]
that's a sketchy part of town it is once
you cross over that [ __ ] that's a spook
i don't even like that target up there i
tell my wife which target is that one
there's a target the victory one yeah oh
you know there's going to be a shoe yeah
there you can smell the gunpowder yeah
where could i go to what's going on oh
please any day now they're going to you
know it's going to be a plane and
they're going to drop pamphlets out
i hate when my wife takes my baby to
that dog you want to get shocked and
shut on your own time that is the one
target
i've like i've lived two times i've gone
to that target there's been a kid
covered in its own [ __ ] crying because
it didn't have a parent and they had to
fight and like nobody cared and i
remember having a call like can somebody
please and they found the mom she was
like halfway across the other end of the
store like that [ __ ] happens all the
time at that time
that's the type of target where i
guarantee you the manager could sell you
could tell you have to [ __ ] there for
half off out back right if you tell them
you'll come back with cash
right after they close he'll meet you
outside and be like hey you want these
got a starbucks in there yeah starbucks
and which way yeah i'm telling you you
know what i'll wait for this how many
which switches have you had lately just
one geez what flavor uh turkey
unbelievable is that place good on
everybody no no no no it's garbage
it was good try it why would you want to
try it like i got a piece of dog [ __ ]
i'm going to cover it with chocolate you
want to try that
1899 with a drink i still got it
on wednesday night [ __ ] even
after driving on set
that was my route that olympic ground
that was ladies and gentlemen i love you
guys
i never want you to think i'm whining to
you
hey
[ __ ] brutal los angeles traffic thing
you guys know me against my best [ __ ]
wishes okay but sometimes you're gonna
go talk to some people you gotta do it
they're gonna talk to you and they're
always in santa monica and they always
want to talk to you at the end of that
day
the [ __ ] drive down there
was a paradise it was the first time i
didn't get in the hov lane i just drove
like regular americans waving at people
i didn't have a car for 60 yards in
front of me whoa i was crossing lanes
it was completely [ __ ] empty i mean i
was like what is going on with the 405.
that never happened the other side going
north bumper bumper dead all right
people waving like
they got stuck
katrina hands
they're waving in
[ __ ] i'm going south and i'm doing
85.
i got there at f i left my house at 10
to 3 and i got the santa monica at 3 19
to the location holy [ __ ] that's how
fast and then i had an exit on the tent
that there was nobody
no there was a kid on a bicycle
nobody even said nothing to him i shot
straight in like nothing when i got out
of there i hadn't seen nothing like that
in a long time now the last time i saw
something like that
i got in that left-hand lane yeah and i
wrote it for about a mile
until i went around it
it doesn't die till you go around the
405. yeah on olympic yeah and it took me
from 2700
santa monica that to [ __ ] the 405 and
it was easy getting back too it took me
an hour the 405 was
men's and men's but the [ __ ]
once you got on it i mean
he just and you can get aggravated yeah
all i do is when i'm driving i go thank
god i don't have to do this five days a
week right exactly oh could you imagine
that would kill you nine to five
it is a [ __ ] nightmare it really
it tests your [ __ ] soul there's
always an accident and it's a
it's just weird it's just weird to even
describe it you know
thank god i had to do it i haven't done
in a long time i was kind of upset last
night i got away with the obama thing
tuesday i had plans to go to marina del
rey oh obama was going to be down in
that thing and then the guy took the gun
out down on temple street right he shut
traffic down for three hours people
don't know what you'll be [ __ ] every
day there's [ __ ] drama and if you get
involved in making all these moves that
you don't need to make you will get
caught in a [ __ ] whirlwind
of [ __ ] traffic and it always happens
when you're on e and you
juice or something today that's great
that's right
what are you doing this weekend lisa
yeah nothing
what am i all uh i'm going to uh
a benefit for the pug rescue oh very
nice your head right in the [ __ ]
computer
unbelievable unbelievable good for you
it's called the punktacular spooktacular
that's a great great that's good [ __ ]
it see what happens when i leave
yeah he's doing a good thing
he giggles like a half a fruitcake he's
doing a service man he's doing the
service good for him so no we we were
just rapping there earlier and it's just
scary i think about it i think about it
now
and i think about my daughter and i
think about like nieces and friends kids
and i think about me getting in a car
when i'm 19 years old
with maybe 1600 hours in my pocket and
maybe
some weed and going cross country with a
barbell and two speakers
landing in basalt for three months not
really having a job for two of those
months and i picked up little gigs
and i could [ __ ] float around and
then i moved to snowmass village
and that's what i was telling you about
when we robbed the [ __ ] that was
just
craziness
god
you know but guess what at that time i
was heartbroken sure i left new jersey
my mom had died
i was in love when i left somebody else
was giving her a stabbing
you know my dreams were the worst
feelings dude
but when i went over there you know what
i got into like a vocation no i got into
colorado mountain college
at first i was gonna go to vocational
school and i checked out the plumbing
course and i was like the same for me i
gotta do something a little bit more
[ __ ] free right i got into the
electrical business and i i was an
electrician when i was up there you know
being young is [ __ ] great but you got
to do [ __ ] sometimes if you don't even
if you go away for one year yeah and
just to give it a shot you know you
gotta go somewhere for one year take
your time right now be angeles or hawaii
but i would go like houston texas for a
year or
no no new orleans i can't say nobody
down i can't be responsible for that
that'll [ __ ] you up over there for a
weekend man really why
crazy it's a little bit crazy new
orleans man i think it's more of a sin
city than vegas right like it's more
it's a different type of [ __ ] city in
vegas i got a camera everywhere right if
i stab you in vegas i'm in jail in 24
[ __ ] no question 24 and a half hours
i'm in jail new orleans they might never
find you they'll never find you yeah
they throw you in one of those levees
they'll bury you under one of those
sausage houses yeah people drink on top
of you for a year before something
smells
it's [ __ ] you know and that's the
reason and i'm not putting down new
orleans by now i just heard you man a
lot of things when i was down there i
didn't dabble when i was down there
right i kept close to the set
i took cars whenever they said
everything right or the hotel right yeah
yeah if i want to walk i'll join a
country club you know what i'm saying
i don't want to [ __ ] walk nowhere i'm
going to walk around i don't know what
the [ __ ] i'm talking about
what are you looking at me all week i'm
not looking at you weird
um i'm excited you're talking about like
like places you go there's there was
this sandwich place i used to live up
above so i'm going to go there i'm
excited to go to boston nice it's going
to be fun
yeah
you know everything you talk about food
in boston well you're going to go to
chinese food you depress me what's
sandwich you get a sandwich here yeah
but go don't monica's getting turkeys
because that's if you're gonna get a
sandwich like if you said you were going
back
to kind of sausage sale i'm gonna get a
pizza yeah the sausage is dripping down
your face but i know you can i got a
turkey with mustard
and cheddar cheese with double tomato
same thing you get in somewhere yeah and
i'm gonna kick in the [ __ ] leg
because you know i can't deal with that
[ __ ] in public
and she says turkey with cheddar i don't
get turkey with cheddar i know you doing
i kick you right in the stomach
party's over
party's over that's it what's this guy
doing
people at home are thinking what the
[ __ ] going on tonight listen what the
[ __ ] you think is going on it's a
wednesday night i got comedy this
weekend in las vegas at the south point
casino that's why
that's why my main man lee is not
allowed this weekend that's why he's
going to the bug
festival and not being [ __ ] vegas
with me
eating stars and losing 20 bucks in the
slot machines and tapping out every time
i go to vegas lee i go to my room the
next morning i wake up to a story
what happened i'm tired what do you mean
we went to upstairs like yeah but then
at two i came down and i was up 800. but
then i went to my room and i couldn't
sleep and i came down and i lost
sickness
and i went and there's a story and i had
some eggs
why don't you think you felt goodly i
don't like 25 centigrade yes you did
that
yes you did yes
is there a fight there this weekend
anything go ahead not nice you know when
i go to vegas man i might like i just
said to you this camera's everywhere
yeah so guess what uncle joey does i
mind my [ __ ] go do your show go to
the room that's it yeah i go to the clan
bar that's how i don't really do the
vegas [ __ ] i just go i'm away from this
trip i'm too [ __ ] old i love to join
you right you know i got friends from uh
grammar school okay
that he's like family right so he takes
me to lunch we go to her breakfast
so that's two meals the the kids come
now he's too old to come he's my age so
his kids come to the comedy shows and
then he we go up to the room and hang
out and give him ufc tickets he's like
my nephew he really [ __ ] is a man
no i'm good
i'll get let you get out of here i'll
read some sponsors you're going to give
me some sheets stabbed me in the long
cut
thank you my friend oh yeah you're a
gentleman and a scholar
look at you mafia three dude doesn't
matter we don't [ __ ] around here was it
fun doing that
was it easy in and out kind of thing oh
yeah it was wrong that's great after
this you're going to ask me questions
lee syed has lost a few pounds on it i
know he uh
i mean listen let's face it lee syed is
basically food poisoning at least i had
to billy goat i love him like a brother
but he's billy god like i'm like a
brother and a nephew
lee science worse than mikey he won't
eat it once he'll try it twice you know
what i'm saying even though the first
time got him a little sick if he could
save a dollar or they have something
special in there leo keep going back but
lee did and looks really good since he's
been on blue apron he's happy him and
his girlfriend do it together
they have a great time i call him he
tells me what he's eating
i mean he was really happy with it i
know you put it down while we were
traveling and i'm picking it up next
week you're picking it up next week for
a reason for less than ten dollars per
meal
blue apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre-portioned ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meals blue
apron knows that when you cook with
incredible ingredients you make
incredible meals so they set the highest
quality standards for their community
family-run farms fisheries ranches
whether it's the japanese ramen noodles
the wild caught alaskan salmon or the
heirloom tomatoes blue apron is bringing
you the best
they're not messing around no more the
recipes are created weekly and not
repeated within a year that means you'll
never get bored your meals have a
variety of recipes or let brew aprons
culinary team just surprise you you're
sitting there you're like i'm having a
shitty day boom a box comes to your door
you open it up guess who it is blue
apron with a salmon a dessert a salad
that's what i'm talking about and you
cook it in less than 30 minutes all
right every meal comes with a
step-by-step
easy to follow recipe card and
pre-portioned ingredients and can be
prepared i was wrong in 40 minutes or
less all right who's better than you
this is what you're going to do check
out this week's menu
spicy beef skewers
cod sandwiches with caper alioli
sicilian style raga tony pasta
seared pork chops and pastrami spiced
salmon are you kidding me or what that's
what we're gonna do i'm gonna get you
your first three meals for free that's
right free that's right free with free
shipping by going to blueapron.com
joey again
i'm giving you three meals
for free
and free shipping by going to
blueapron.com
joey you'll love how good it feels and
taste and to create home-cooked meals
with blue apron so don't wait plus you
learn how to cook you save the recipe
cards okay who's better than you you
want to impress girls guys you want to
impress guys this it's the holiday
season you want to live there like a
schlub
that's right three free meals and free
shipping blue apron.com
joey again blue apron a better way to
cook all right
who's better than you all right let me
drop some real knowledge on you people
yeah there we go
i've been trying to tell you people for
a long time uncle joey's trying to help
you out in more ways than one you want
to have friends
you want to learn how to mingle
do i got something for you for the
holidays hellotushy.com
amen you're looking at me going jerry
what are you talking about but days are
back [ __ ]
you're sitting there going joey what's a
big day of the day
is this little thing that's
when i first bumped into a bidet it was
next to my mom's toilet
it had a hot water thing and a cold
water thing and you sat there after you
took a dump or you took a little leak or
you sometimes i just sat on the bidet
you have nothing to do you just sit on
the bidet it's cold water hitting your
little muffler right
and guess what for a while there they
disappeared but people started walking
around they got hemorrhoids people got
problems
so but days are back the devices that
spray your little buck clean with water
like i said i grew up with a bidet in my
house they are tremendous now
thanks to tushy sleek bidets that clip
on to your existing toilets and they
spray your butt completely clean with
fresh water to get your muffler
sparklers so you're not sitting there
with bacteria in your muffler which
causes hemorrhoids and yeast infections
and just rotten ass all in general okay
but days are also better for the
environment because more no paper more
trees i remember one time i took
mushrooms and i had diarrhea and i'm
sitting there i'm thinking to myself how
many trees they had to come from this
toilet paper i'm using i don't need that
in my life that wouldn't happen that
time can you imagine eating mushrooms or
sitting on your bidet never mind you get
the [ __ ] hot water one that's when
you're really hopping up and down now i
told you bidets are better for the
environment and they use one final water
all right now tushy stands behind that
product
four
60 guaranteed days all right so i don't
know for 60 or 30. i forget let's go
with 30 all right sir
who's better than you listen you want to
surprise somebody for the holidays i've
already had two people show up at shows
with the boxers and they love this thing
nice i installed one in my back bathroom
i've used this twice it is tremendous
wait till that cold water hits your
scrotum unbelievable your head blows up
especially in the morning you don't know
where you're at you got amnesia you know
what i'm saying while you're drinking
coffee like that cold water it's like
somebody's spitting in your muffler
tremendous you know i'm saying drop it
at least i what do you think of it oh my
god it's
because when i when we spoke last i had
just installed it and this is now how i
don't know how many weeks later but it's
changed my life where were you without
it if if jerry snips your muffler right
now what will he smell daisy jerry jerry
you can you can
lick my muffler oh almost worry free oh
nice it's been a few hours since i've
been home
anyway you've been watching for 30 days
you're nice and clean everybody's happy
and your wife likes it right everybody
uses it my she she had never even tried
one before and she said it was a game
changer it was it's
amazing
i was thinking about it today you asked
me a question what level do i put it at
and i look down there's not really
levels there's no numbers but i i just
put almost all the way to 10. it's and
you just well you're a big guy you got a
lot of tacos oh yeah you got mayonnaise
and lettuce and stuff i know but then
you goat cheese and all that el rancho
tacos yeah at the mother-in-law's house
what do you think is mixing all that yum
yum food
if you want to have a nice gift for
somebody for the holidays and that's a
little uh stocking stuffer this is the
perfect gift right what we're gonna do
for you is listeners because we want you
to have a clean mufflers go to
hellotushy.com
church i'll tell you what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna give you ten percent off for
the holidays again nice this is the
perfect gift for the holidays all right
hellotushy.com
church you're gonna love this okay
hellotushy.com keep your muffler clean
especially for the holidays why go on
match.com if you got a bidet all right
you know why you're going to start with
go to hellotushy.com
slash church 10 percent off that's what
we're offering yeah right right now also
i want to introduce somebody to the
church that i bumped into in the
weirdest way
i was talking to somebody one day about
dieting and about that i was going to
jujitsu and how i liked
uh not really eating before my meals now
i've always uh been very loyal and
honest with the shake in the morning but
in life you get used to something and
sometimes you eat something at seven
that's what's wrong with diet that at
first you have that egg with the one uh
slice of uh uh uh egg mcmuffin like like
uh what do you call an english muffin
yeah absolutely and with a piece of
cheese and you with a piece of bacon and
you have your little water that works
for about four months and you do lose
weight but then you lose you go right
through that so you have to switch it up
from time to time so a friend of mine
recommended this vanilla coconut meal
replacement okay by primal let me tell
you something this stuff
kept me full you know i'm a fat [ __ ] i
smoke marijuana all right i would have
one of these at eight in the morning and
i would not eat until i got back from
jujitsu damn 2 15. and you felt great
the whole tremendous no business no
nothing easy no we didn't feel weak damn
some water three four ice cubes two
scoops you're off and [ __ ] running
and you were sad and satisfied too you
didn't get hungry none of that [ __ ]
that's crazy that's great man [ __ ] primo
fuel is one of the cleanest ways to
build muscle burn fat and starve off
hunger why
because what it contains is pretty
unparallel in every serving you get 20
grams of whey protein isolate one of the
highest bioavailable proteins which
means your body can use it better any
proteins when building muscle nine grams
the highest quality coconut fat and the
super fat that curbs hunger and packs a
wallop without promoting benefits
primo fuel has no added sugar
artificial sweeteners or unwanted extra
all right they also have the 21 day
total body transformation which i'm
going to try along with lisa
i'm going to tell you something i've
tried their products i've tried their
almond uh
their almond coconut bar and i tell you
what they have some great tasting stuff
do me a favor go to
primalblueprint.com joey for more info
if you like something use cult
coupon code joey diaz and check out for
10 off your entire order again go to
primalblueprint.com
joey i think it's last joey ds slash
joey diaz for more info and use coupon
code
joey diaz in parentheses at checkout for
10 off your entire order i'm gonna tell
you something you know me dawg i don't
[ __ ] you [ __ ] the holidays
are coming you're gonna be out there
eating cookies and [ __ ] whatnot okay
this is the best time to watch what the
[ __ ] no question this is the time of the
year when i really [ __ ] watch it
because i know you gained 15 pounds this
is the way to do it a nice little way
[ __ ] protein shake in the morning
that's great with a [ __ ] banana
whatever the [ __ ] you're doing but this
is the way to do it the primal vanilla
and they also have a chocolate coconut
which will knock your socks off too i've
mixed and matched from time to time you
know me i don't like doing the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] every day so do me a favor
give it a shot like i said i'm going to
start the 21 day total bollock
transformation with lee and then we're
going to change this [ __ ] that's it lee
and i are really going to go for it this
it looks interesting it is interesting
it it teach how to burn fat for fuel and
prevent weight loss proper fitness
techniques that save time and starve off
injury and burnout and lifestyle changes
that reduce stress
strengthen immunity and increase energy
we all need that [ __ ] especially during
the holidays one of the most stressful
times of the [ __ ] year it all starts
here
com slash primalblueprint.com dears for
more info on all this use coupon code
joey diaz in parentheses at checkout for
ten percent off your entire who's
[ __ ] better than you [ __ ]
nice jerry larocca what do you got going
on you're going here you're going to
pompano yeah please going for the
[ __ ] whatever convention via flappers
in claremont this weekend and then
laughs in seattle november fourth and
fifth if anybody gives a [ __ ] i got a
brand new cd out called pickle dick on
itunes and amazon you can pick up jerry
roach and pickle dick it's 7.99 and uh
my podcast the ramble and i also have a
podcast where i talk action figures and
video games called the power pals of
some of my buddies so yeah check all
that [ __ ] out man thank you for having
me oh bro i miss you dude you're the
[ __ ] king i the mission too man i
wanted i i
got a chance to do one of these games
yes and i had never done it before yeah
and
they sent me two of them in the mail
this is great
and i've never played a game before
that's why you said did you play do you
play arcades back in the day did you
ever [ __ ] with that stuff like pac-man
right did you ever do any of that stuff
because those were kind of hot back then
right like i like uh
you know pew pew the [ __ ] galaga
gallagher yeah of course okay gallagher
is my [ __ ] battle i love
pac-man miss pac-man
this pac-man is my world i'll get stoned
and go to a dry cleaner on purpose
all these little mexican dry cleaners
around here they all got mixed back
there they got one of those games like
four and five four games in one yeah
yeah so you can pick it i will sit there
throughout the whole dryer 40 minute
[ __ ] run and roll a ten dollar
quarters i will go purposely and smoke
weed in the car and come back there
that's great [ __ ] soda and i will sit
there and play gallagher yeah and then
i'll play miss pac-man i'll put my
[ __ ] add whatever the [ __ ] kicks in i
can flash back some beat
and i get the [ __ ] out of there that's
how it so that's great i never really uh
i don't know how this works you know i
used to go to drug dealers homes that
had
that
yeah sure man and i would sit there
while they weighed their coke and i
didn't know when they would argue and
yell at each other and they would play
madden 400. of course that is yeah man
and i never really got it i always knew
that
i didn't need these in my life
of course these things will [ __ ]
addict you oh man i'm 53 i never really
played one and uh well i mean this is
like the best i'm not lying this is
probably the best time to get in it
because obviously now the systems are
just so much more powerful again and
this is i'm telling you
and everything i've heard about this
game
is these are like it's like you're you
know the whole thing will probably maybe
last like 15 20 hours to play it you
know i've implemented that's usually
what they are and it's like you're
watching a great tv show it's like it's
an interactive episode of law and order
where you know it's it's great a lot of
them they some you know how long have
you been playing these i've been playing
them since i was out of the [ __ ] when
i was four years old my mom got me a
colego vision and that's how her and i
bonded it was just my mom and i you know
because she hadn't met my you know she
just met my dad her boyfriend who ended
up being my dad so there's two of us and
we would just play we just play video
games all like when i come i have to do
homework and then i play video games
with my mom and then the the game
changer of them all was because the
atari came out right the atari 2600 and
then it just got shitty all of a sudden
it was just shitty video game after
shitty video game and then they made a
video game for the movie e.t that was
historically the worst video game ever
made like it barely turned on when you
put it in they just had to rush it out
because the movie was so popular and it
literally killed the video game industry
for about two or three years it killed
it it was just dead they they even have
a famous landfill where there's
something they buried like
two million copies of that et game
somewhere in the [ __ ] desert in
nevada
and um they actually did a documentary
where they dug them all back up and sure
enough everything was an urban legend
but they were all [ __ ] in there and
then nintendo just changed the game with
super mario brothers and they had their
system and it brought everybody back and
you know about this lee also i i
i'm not a good gamer i get bored after
two weeks because i'm not as good if it
says if it takes a good game or 20 hours
it takes me like 100 hours sure so i get
i get angry but
when you said you play with your mom i
play i used to play mario yeah on uh
what is it on the
first game boy oh yeah the first game
boys yeah of course and and then so what
joe what it did was it just it brought
the arcade into your living room right
my mom used to set the timer on the
stove yeah so the my her me and my
brother because she could take turns yes
and so and we would uh and then and then
and i just it was just joe it just never
went away dude it was like it was the
same thing as listening to pink floyd
for the first time you know how you know
when you listen to pink floyd for the
first time you're like holy [ __ ] i'm in
for life i'm gonna go wherever these
guys take me that's what happened with
video games it was at super mario
brothers when that [ __ ] dropped in 85 i
was like forget it i'll wherever these
guys want to take you you still play
these every day
every day i got my girlfriend playing
she was never into this [ __ ] now she
loves it like there there are some
tremendous video games out there there's
their video games where as far as story
and even the acting
rivals films i mean they're just there's
some great stories being told in that
medium it's great [ __ ] man it's good
it's for the fun man i was
never
never
um not it
it's a man there's some things that you
learn that you look at and you go you
know what
that looks like fun in my world listen
everybody knows
and for years people have been thinking
i'm a gamer sure because i like smoking
reefer and kicking back sure
but i thought that that would just
shock me to death that's anxiety
i see how much people argue yeah where i
would go to get drugs for a long time it
was just gamers get into the yelling at
each other on the headset [ __ ] you like
you're [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] like you know what this is the last
[ __ ] i need raising my [ __ ] blood
pressure yeah you know what i'm telling
you
stay away if that's i'm telling you
right now stay away from games like call
of duty and john madden because those
are the ones that bring out the crazy in
you okay do [ __ ] like this that's the
one the cia
a game like mafia three you don't even
have to play with anybody it's like you
it's like escapism you just [ __ ] put
this on you can even put on some
headphones man and you just did you just
enter this world you don't talk to
anybody you're just sitting there it's
great um
now yeah like i'm telling you dude it's
it's a lot they get better and better
you know
can i plug something real quick a buddy
of mine named tom bissell is a fantastic
this guy covered the iraqi war all that
[ __ ] for like the new yorker harper's
he's a legit writer and he wrote an
amazing book
called extra lives why video games
matter and he talks about how video
games just been a constant throughout
his life and he talks about like how he
played grand theft auto and it even it
gave him a real-life coke
addiction playing the g it's a
fascinating book it's called extra lives
by video games matter by tom bissell
it's it's it's fat the dudes he's
amazing he writes videos if i get sick
at night
playing video games so one night just
going
right let me try this let me try this
i'm in the mood to do a line of [ __ ]
right
i would have a living heart attack right
if i did a line of coke and played it
and played a game and had a focus on the
game that is a [ __ ]
he writes him now for a living and uh
i'll tell you this story real quick he
said you'll love this you'll love this
he was at comic-con talking about a game
once right and i hope i don't even know
if i can tell this story but i'll change
everything so he had written a game in a
series of a popular series of video
games and this game took place before
the main series and there was a weapon
in the game right and that was common
throughout the series and he's taking
questions at comic-con and this nervous
uh pardon me but that is completely
impossible for that photon laser to have
been in that game because if this game
takes place 55 years before the events
of the first game that photon laser
wouldn't have been invented like he gets
angry
tom just went into the microphone and he
goes
you know none of this [ __ ] is real right
he thought it would kill he thought he
was gonna they bombed they were mad they
were like [ __ ] you it's not real they
were blowing them
he thought he was gonna
oh this is my this will be a funny line
this will this will kill the room and
they were just like [ __ ] this guy this
is real that photon laser should not be
in that video again
oh man you can't [ __ ] with nerds guys
dude nerds can't do it you know oh it's
amazing you know you talk about cocaine
have you ever read stephen king
yeah
misery did you ever read misery i read
like six or seven of his books when i
was locked up yeah that's why i got
hooked on stephen king do you know uh
misery he said it just recently he said
misery's cocaine oh please he goes the
book misery the the
kathy bates character that's coke that's
coke it's your biggest fan it's your
best friend but the minute you try to
turn your back on it it [ __ ] kills
you like it was amazing like he said
that book is that [ __ ] that book is 100
about cocaine but i always think of it
too as kathy bates and misery are like
all these nerds now who just [ __ ] about
every little thing that yeah dr strange
would never you know like all this [ __ ]
i love it i look i just want to see him
i just want to i wish i wish i knew
about it so i could go down there and
argue with him
yeah i know i know
but how funny is that he just goes to
the mic and he goes you guys know none
of this [ __ ] is real
i would love to like know about a game
and just kind of break balls
[ __ ] nintendo brothers is better
[ __ ] you punk [ __ ] suckers
there's a guy who does that i forgot his
name but he goes on wait a second what
do you do this dude this dude go he'll
play call of duty i forgot i'm just i'm
i if you're listening i'm sorry for not
giving you credit i forgot your name but
he'll go and call it you know you have
voice chats like all 18 people in the
game you can all talk about joining the
game with other people oh he's playing
he'd play against each other all these
people no no you just start playing a
stranger it's like it's like the arcade
remember you play like someone would
walk up next to you
yeah that's how it was i don't want to
play with you you don't want to play
yeah
this is my [ __ ]
this dude [ __ ] with people he'll be
like hey what y'all doing what y'all
playing oh you're playing that game okay
you know what i'm playing i'ma suck that
dick dude and they're like what
and he's like now i'm gonna go over
there and i'm a sucky dick and they're
like [ __ ] you you're not gonna
and he puts it on youtube it's [ __ ]
hilarious this guy
it's the funniest thing
all these [ __ ] nerds are starting
yelling at him like [ __ ] some of them
get it they start laughing but other
ones are like
what he's like i'm gonna go yeah no no
let's go over here now this is what the
flags over here okay get that flag i'ma
suck that dick
what what
i wish i wish they get so fired up oh
bro it's nicely the industry that
comic-con has become
and i'm like oh my god unbelievable i've
had people call me with the dumbest
ideas i would never right in my life sit
in a booth with a jersey on oh and talk
about the longest shirt i would be so
[ __ ] embarrassed right right that's
the you know what what's cool about
comic-con if you're in a movie now right
and you get to go up like a rock star
talk about the new movie but then you
see the people who like the guy was in
one episode of buck rogers back in 1979.
you know what i mean and he's sitting
there in the costume signing autographs
yeah i wouldn't mind going to a comic
con
from 1960 to 1975. when it was low-key
the tv when i came from cuba maybe the
guy that was on the green hornet oh yeah
maybe the guy from room 222 maybe the
guy from
you know the waltons maybe bad ass dude
one of the guys from the rifleman maybe
dude that would have been badass you got
to meet chuck connors back then how sick
would that be you know maybe somebody
from the jeffersons yeah and then sit in
the booth and take pictures and you can
ask them questions
i think it's when they mix too much
stuff that's good i don't care how many
days it is yeah they just overwhelm me
it's very well i i would have an anxiety
attack you know me i love going and it
gets it gets here's how and this is a
true story here's how packed comic-con
gets there was and and how just have you
been the only other ones across the
country or just just mainly san diego
because that's the bit i mean but when i
was there one year and i was able to get
into hall h and hall h is where they
screen all the movies right where they
show the previews for avengers before
anybody sees it that kind of [ __ ] and
they have all the avengers come out all
the x-men come out up on stage and uh so
i'm there yes yeah well the x-men come
on this is always my [ __ ] mind i lose
my mind are you really oh god yeah how
old are we there i'm in my late 30s and
i was like yeah jumping up and down like
an idiot i loved it like the beatles
[ __ ] yeah it might as well be shea
stadium absolutely it was muslim in the
cowboys winning super bowl i was going
to deal with ladies and gentlemen one
guy i don't know the other guy went to
college for four years he wants to go
see bugs this weekend
three years of college
i didn't go to college and i want to go
see robert downey jr dressed up like
iron man but so we we go in and i see
this guy and you know the people that go
into costumes right to do the cosplay
where they'll dress up like spiderman
all this [ __ ] this guy was a dead on
hugh jackman from wolf like wolverine he
had the ev it was insane he had the
makeup the hair everything and he was
cut he was and he was like a tall he was
a he just looked just like him and i was
like holy sh i want to go tell him like
dude that you that's an amazing costume
and then i go into that hall hugh
jackman comes out and he goes yeah i
kind of had a laugh i went around a
couple hours earlier today dressed up as
wolverine nobody said anything like
that's how crazy it is like he goes one
person was like yeah you look a little
short that's all they said that was it
he that was him he was just walking
around and he could he went in nobody
even bugged him like hugh jackman
dressed as everybody's favorite
character walking around and that's how
crazy it is you don't even have time to
really go is that guy standing next to
me really hugh jackman's like hey [ __ ]
it let's just like it's crazy it's it's
crazy
but i i mean i love that [ __ ] dude it's
fun man i love it this vampire is down
there oh there's everything then they
have all the strippers dressed up like
jessica rabbit handing out the two for
one passes for the strip clubs and all
that stuff yeah they do they have all
them they have all those people then
they have like the the jesus people who
are like repent now you're going to hell
you're worshiping false idols all that
kind of stuff they have the protesters
it gets crazy joy would be on their side
it's crazy now it's like we're going to
hang out with protests
for people to hate me i got enough
problems
that's what i want to do go down there
we got to figure out a way to do this we
got to get you in a comic-con and i'll
sit you down for like a weekend and make
you an instant expert on like one video
game just you can talk [ __ ] all the time
i'll do it that would be the best oh
[ __ ] that would be so funny that would
be great you know i wouldn't even know
where to start the lingo
you know i wouldn't know where the [ __ ]
to start i've seen these things for
years
they've been around since i was
shoplifting it yeah toys r us
i used to look at this
that's the truth hey you know what's
amazing too is you think about it like
oh my god like how much how much worse
games were back then than they are now
like visually and all that but they were
still 50 bucks it's net that's almost
never changed
they never stopped getting paid yeah
those guys okay so tom writes in his
book that he went to uh he went to go
interview the creator of a popular
franchise right and had a little office
up in silicon valley right he goes up
there he pulls in the office just all
the people who work and this is from the
top of the company to the bottom of the
company that all work on this one video
game he said every literally every car
was a lamborghini in the parking lot
those dudes are making
so much [ __ ] money it is unbelievable
literally every car was a [ __ ]
lamborghini these guys are just ballers
and that's i mean they make i mean that
that that industry makes more than
hollywood it probably probably makes
more than porn like it's crazy how much
that and it's funny because a lot of
people like oh like you like i could
never get into that it's not for me but
there's even people nowadays who have
never played a single video game in
their life except madden and every year
they're in line at midnight to go buy
the new madden you know because or they
go by the new nba game or do their do
call of duty they might not touch any
other [ __ ] video game but they're
going to go buy that one you know it
just it it's so ingrained in everything
now it's fascinating like you just
missed it by a couple of years dude had
you been born like four or five years
later you would know everything about
video games it's crazy if you think
about it
you would know ever you would just it
would be because you would have grown
you would have started right when like
you know atari started taking over and i
mean it was it was crazy man like it was
like that was just what we did you would
go hang out with kids you didn't like
just because they had a new game that
you didn't have and you wanted to go
play it like it was just that's how it
would that's it like it was like oh man
we would go around and every kid in the
neighborhood had a different game so i
gotta go hang out with tommy today
because he has metroid and you know this
kid over here has got you know and we
just that was what we did i always had
bad luck with games oh when i was a kid
i was lose to my mother in participation
i stuck a bean from please don't spill
the beans right here
i had to go to the hospital
i didn't have patience i i you know when
i got into i got into shooting pool
and i realized how crazy i got one day
right just competitive you mean yeah i
got very competitive yeah like a young
age and i said i can't feel that way
well see that's what i stopped a game
like this there's no competition it's
all by yourself that's that's why you
would love something like this or you
could you could do something like this
so if you get crazy to stay away from
like the madden games stay away from
like the cause those those are like the
death match games
like call of duty where it's like you
and five other people against six other
dudes and you're just shooting it and
they're all talking [ __ ] on the headsets
and yeah you know and that's what guy
that's like i [ __ ] you yeah that's when
all that [ __ ] happened now can you just
play by yourself absolutely that's what
this one is no what about the like the
call of duty a couple of them have some
online uh single player campaigns yeah
but right now there's a game called
overwatch that i'm playing the [ __ ] out
of and sadly that one is not you have to
play with other people but it's the best
like it's like crack that game i just
all i do is play it every i wake up play
for a little bit then write some jokes
then come back and play oh it's amazing
like it's uh how many hours a day you
play four
oh yeah at least because i'll i'll be up
until about three in the morning not you
know playing for sure oh and i love it
it's 20 hours a week plus oh no question
it's like a job there it is i'm saying
to you [ __ ] i love it that's why i
knew
i knew that that was like i had to pick
between all my vices right if i play
games ain't nobody gonna suck my little
nuts
no it happens it'll happen
you know a dude
several people have gotten married
playing that game warcraft like it's
just an online
lord of the rings type game right and
this guy
they they got married in the game and
then people end up getting married in
real life from it like it's crazy dude
it's it's uh it's it's a culture in and
of itself our video games it's
it's uh it's fascinating it's i'm so
happy that you're in one now this is
great dude i'm going to play this and
i'm going to hear you let's play after
let's shut this down we'll switch over
to periscope
and we'll watch jerry larocha
play the game for a little while and
teach me how to [ __ ] play i've never
played a game before i've never played
this one but i i i can uh once you've
played one you you can get them it's
it's it's pretty good
hey ladies and gentlemen all right
uh i want to thank
blue apron i want to thank
primal fuel
i want to thank
hellotushy.com i want to thank my main
[ __ ] over at honor.com
always never forget on it i love their
supplements i love uh
apple brain
alpha brain the shroom tech sport the
shroom tech immune always go over there
and check out their uh
monthly get 10 percent off what do you
put in that lee you put church
c-h-u-r-c-h knock yourself out have a
great weekend see you in las vegas or
see you november 11th at the wilbur
theater on november 12th at the fox
woods [ __ ] casino stay black
have a great weekend
see you on monday thanks for having me
dude jerry roach i love you wake up
man
uh just find me on twitter at roacha
r-o-c-h-a
roach comedy my website
jerryroachercomedy.com lisa yeah have a
great weekend my little brother be safe
i'm gonna miss you in vegas have fun
buddy you got you too
so it was this he just in and out like a
couple of days it was
this
hmm
you